the midterm elections are a little more
than a week away voters will decide
which party controls Congress the latest
CBS News poll show Republicans are
likely to take control of the House of
Representatives while the Senate is
projected to be a 50-50 split with
Democrats holding the tie-breaking vote
of Vice President Kamala Harris the
fastest growing group of Voters could
play a key role in Battleground States
Asian Americans Nancy Chen is here with
more on that good morning Nancy hey good
morning to you Michelle that's right
Asian Americans are increasing in
numbers and so is their power on
Election Day in 2020 voter participation
increased exponentially in Battleground
States like Georgia and Nevada as well
as others like Texas and California and
that makes this year one to watch
I'm with Jay Chen for congress with
control of Congress up for grabs Orange
County California is home to one of the
closest races in the country so let's go
win this my accent is broken but my
heart is full but the heated campaign
between Democrat Jay Chen and incumbent
Republican Michelle Steele in a district
that's nearly 30 percent Asian American
also showcases the growing political
power of this rapidly changing Community
this seat was drawn to be an Asian
plurality seat it was designed
specifically so that Asian American
voters would have a very strong voice
while far from a monolith Asian
Americans are the fastest growing racial
group in the U.S with more than 13
million eligible to vote this November
Asian American voters could make a huge
difference this election you know that's
what we're most excited about Nadia
Belkin heads the newly formed
Asian-American power Network an alliance
of organizations advocating for progress
of issues she says Asian Americans could
be the margin of Victory and key
Battleground states which is why the
Coalition collectively launched a 10
million dollar campaign to mobilize
voters we have voters that are hungry to
participate in the process it's about
making sure that we are reaching out and
engaging them in ways that resonate with
them Belkin says attempts to Galvanize
voters are happening on the Grassroots
level but campaigns should do more some
democratic organizers agree we're not
seeing that Asian Americans have to be
their top no we just want to say that we
want to be included but in States like
Texas and Georgia where there are large
Asian American populations Outreach is
growing and candidates are finding
success this upcoming election is an
opportunity to organize aapi communities
in Texas in 2020 Asian American voters
in Georgia mobilized in unprecedented
numbers doubling their turnout and
helping Democrats flip control of the
U.S Senate we are a party for every
American in the lead-up to this year's
midterms the Republican National
Committee opened Asian American
community outreach centers in California
Washington State Nevada Georgia and
Texas we're looking at these areas where
there are a lot of Asian American voters
different Asian American communities and
this investment is a considerable one
harmeet Dillon is a member of the
Republican National Committee and
coordinates Grassroots Outreach I think
what's really important is that we start
these efforts and continue them year
round while Asian Americans have
historically trended Democratic
Republicans now see an opportunity to
make inroads what does this all say
about the Asian American Community there
is a lot of of beauty and it's time I
think for people to start asking
questions and be curious about our
diversity be curious about the languages
that we speak and the cultures that we
carry with us it's about creating a
multi-racial democracy
we should mention that congresswoman
still declined our request for an
interview and that Harmony Dylan who we
featured in our story there is
representing president Trump in the
January 6 trial both Democratic and
Republican operatives they stress the
need for community outreach centers that
are open even when there is not an
election taking place to bring in new
voters for the future a lot of this is
just making it more accessible but also
making it more relatable the the want to
participate is there it's just about
seeing somebody who recognizes your
background no matter what party you're
talking about if you're not out there in
the field talking to people I mean
that's the difference whether it's
election season or not yeah Nancy thank
you very much